a DC fighting game from the creators of
mortal calm my holy [ __ ] I am completely
unprepared for this sorry about that
one sec alright that's better let's do
this injustice gods among us so
injustice gods among us is a fighting
game created by the creative team behind
Mortal Kombat and the creative team
behind Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe
naturally people are gonna want to
compare injustice to both those games I
don't think that's quite fair although
I'm gonna use them as comparisons in
some cases injustice gods among us has
its own fighting system that's kind of
like the Mortal Kombat fighting system
of Mortal Kombat that came out in 2011
it doesn't fight completely like Mortal
Kombat does you do see similarities but
it was surprisingly easy to jump into
injustice starting out you learned that
everyone has their one-two-three combo
or one-two combo throughout the game
you're actually surprised how much you
concentrate on the combos not as much
the special moves then you start
learning how you can link special moves
in with the combos in that it's good for
beginners beginners have their
one-two-three combo system and then as
you advance and start becoming familiar
with the characters you start linking
moves in ways it is like evolution and
you would think you'd be like oh yeah
that's called a fighting game you would
be surprised how many fighting games
miss the concept of it can't play the
same one month after playing it as it
did the first day you played it there
has to be evolution as you evolve and
you adapt you should be able to string
together more combos and become more of
a badass and it keeps the replay value
there injustice gods among us I felt did
that really well and it does not play at
all like Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe I
thought to myself alright Shazam's and
Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe superman's
and Mortal Kombat vs. DC so it would
have been easy for them just to port the
characters over and be like I know they
play identically to how they did in that
game but they don't they played
completely differently I like that props
to the team they were like alright we're
not gonna make it a Mortal Kombat clone
we're definitely not gonna make it a
Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe clone
injustice gods among us is its own game
stringing together some of the combos
I'm not going to say they're easy but
it's natural
he's play you're like oh yeah that would
work and it did work some of the more
advanced combos not so easy some of the
gameplay aspects are kind of broken like
projectiles
not everyone has projectile moves so
when you have Deathstroke Deathstroke is
an [ __ ] he's a douchebag you're
fighting against him he's just like bam
bam bam
you're like wow you're just shootin the
[ __ ] out of me from across the screen it
reminded me of Street Fighter 2 you
remember that [ __ ] Tyger Tyger Tyger
Tyger Tyger Tyger imagine that but the
fireballs are going as fast as what
bullets so some balancing issues in some
aspects of the game all in all though
pretty solid you will kick ass with
Catwoman Harley Quinn Joker whoever you
want to invest your time in perfecting
you're going to be a badass with that
person and everyone has this special
move it's the circle button on the ps3
like Superman you push it his hits now
hit harder Batman pushes circle these
Batarang circle around him they really
personalize the characters they do a
really good job at making the characters
feel like individuals you see the
personalities come through with their
character and you're like Oliver Queen
is awesome he's like Tony Stark meets
Hawkeye Oliver Queen and one of the new
modes they have this clash if someone's
doing a combo against you and you're on
your second life bar you push forward
and r2 and they back up and they say
something to each other and then they
just go across the screen they clash
it's this big explosion and if you win
the clash it gets them totally off your
ass but I liked how some of the
characters had it personalized like when
Solomon Grundy's going up against Green
Arrow really oh man no hurt Grundy green
arrows like arrow man yes hurt Grundy
can they fly at each other in they clash
it was pretty cool I liked that kind of
[ __ ] I love injustice gods among us
because it really gets to play on what
it is
Mortal Kombat vs. DC wasn't entirely a
Mortal Kombat game and wasn't entirely a
DC game it had to meet in the middle
somewhere nothing really got to shine
and justice gods among us is like
alright well you don't have fatalities
but they do have these really ridiculous
moves that's personalized to everybody
example when you're Superman you're
super meters full hit l2 and r2 Superman
hit him up into outer space fly up there
hit them back down to earth everyone
else is different depending on who you
play as that was really cool I like the
level interaction too it'll be in like a
jet hangar there are missiles hanging up
there are toolboxes you can grab them
and just chuck them at your enemy but if
you're one of the weaker characters you
just kind of use it to get away from
your opponent you're like no I wanted to
hit him over the head with it called
gods among us but I guess not everyone
in Indy sees it God and you have
multi-tiered levels you can hit guys
with a powerful move they go flying
through the wall ridiculous [ __ ] happens
like a wrecking ball hits him up against
the wall go crashing down I mean it gets
absurd it was cool to see in this game
because you really have to play if the
fact that these guys are powerful and
they can really take hit and you really
feel that yeah it's called gods among us
and you feel like you're playing as gods
even when you're not a god you still
feel badass online modes really cool and
to keep you coming back and keep you
fighting people
they have these daily challenges that'll
be like I'll win five matches in a row
and the next day they'll have something
else in the next day something else I
like the fact that they have new
challenges every day keeps you coming
back keeps it fresh gives you something
to shoot for some of my gripes and
injustice don't have to do with the
gameplay per se but they have to do with
some of the execution of some of the
elements of the game like they have the
STAR Labs it's pretty much like the
challenge tower in Mortal Kombat getting
through them isn't the hard part getting
three stars and every one of them is
that's like pull your hair out kind of
frustration right there what do you get
for it in Mortal Kombat you cleared the
challenge tower you got some Molina
costume granted the costume wasn't
terrible we gamers were pervs we love
arts love you looking game checks well
for that being the prize at the end of
the challenge tower that wasn't quite
enough you think they would have learned
by now but nope you clear the star
challenges what do you get a flash skin
that's it I would have liked to have
seen a character in the game you know
you ripped all your hair out and the
stress caused you to lose 20 years off
your life here's a character good job
man and that's one of the other
frustrations in this game is not even
specifically this game but this is just
where gaming's going in general there's
no unlockable characters the characters
you will get later on there Dale states
ultimately injustice gods among us if
you want the whole game as a $75 game
kind of success you remember the time
when fighting games had characters that
you would unlock from gameplay that [ __ ]
was awesome I would be up all night long
playing Tekken 3 I mean look I need all
the characters I like unlocking
characters through gameplay that just
makes you feel more accomplished anyone
could pay 15 to 20 bucks and get four
characters why would we give you things
for free that'd be stupid for us no it
isn't pleasing your fans and making them
feel accomplished when playing your game
that's actually smart business and the
story mode while good isn't you blow
your mind away great it's really cool
but it's not as long as the Mortal
Kombat story mode again comparing it to
Mortal Kombat I guess the Mortal Kombat
story mode is like the definitive Mortal
Kombat story in the last Mortal Kombat
game there will not be a movie that
encompasses Mortal Kombat 1 2 & 3 as
well as the story mode Mortal Kombat
story mode an injustice gods among us it
was cold but in the end I won't play
through the story again and at least in
the Mortal Kombat story mode you've got
a couple of characters by the end this
one you get a Superman skin no
characters at all so injustice gods
among us is really easy just to dive
right into the combat system is good for
beginners and it involves and advances
as a fighting game should you start
stringing together bigger combos and
it's all natural it feels so natural
this game online spun you have really
cool challenges these challenges these
extra things will keep you entertained
for a very long time it's a solid
fighting game if you were a fan of
Mortal Kombat you loved DC characters
skip this game there's no reason not to
at all I will say as a fighting game
injustice gods among us is worth buying
at full price that's the $60 full price
not necessarily the 15 more dollars
you're gonna spend on DLC so injustice
gods among us have you played it what
did you think about it and who would you
like to see as DLC or an unlockable
character if they did unlockable
characters which they don't apparently
whoever you want to see comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]